so immer sucht der mensch beziehung zum
göttlichen im eigenen herzen der natur
oder jeder religion spiritueller weg
sind vielseitig im dritten teil von der
spirituellen weg sind wir unterwegs im
fall poschiavo finger im norden als
puschlav bekannt dass diese wichtige
verbindung zwischen nord und süd
zwischen der schweiz und italien
aber das tal verbindet nicht nur es
trend nämlich katholiken und
protestanten dass ich lange so schlimm
dass man vom nordirland von der schweiz
gerettet und ich mache jetzt natürlich
wisse ob das immer so ist für 100 jahre
nach der reformation
[Musik]
das ist sehr eklig der blickte aber zum
lago di poschiavo
wir sind toll beim 800 meter über dem
see auf der alb sandro mio dieses
paradies ist das dort seit china populär
und sie bald riske oderufer im sommer
und über grenz- oder europa
obwohl die noa bank
was fasziniert sie aber in ordnung ganz
einfach alles jeden tag gestand ist
natürlich enorm natürlich die mama für
jede person und die größte sache ist
dass dankbar sein dass der rhetorisch
dass ich da oben schaffen genau die die
händler mit dem shuffle nicht darf
schaffen und das für mich das ein
privileg und wenn die sache aber durch
höhere macht ich würde dir dein leben
schön getanzt erleben welche schönste
war einfach passieren oder
ich habe gehört dass sie hier mal s klo
stock sie glaube aber wir sind
wahnsinnig weit oben wie ich gut denn
sonne viele mehr und das klo sterne
das ist ganz einfach und ganz klar
denken sich gehört der sich kroes ixias
die jetzige see und wird beide flanken
einfach übernommen
dass der durchgang umgeht so schwierig
war oder und die flanken europa tour
gegangen
das lange nicht stabilisiert oder
erdrutsch thailand alles der ettinger
die südhänge bewirtschafter und eine
route zu machen oder
und wenn ich salome jol der erste ort
vom herberge oder und jetzt machen wir
das gleiche
das macht uns sehr glücklich in regionen
bei uns die leute herbergen und und
diese schönheit vor dem ort und diese
kraft diese ruhe und die natur einfach
mit zu genießen
das wäre gerne unter schlüssel dazu
ergab
ja
[Musik]
und ist ein alter fehler
das ist sehr alt eine für die ältere
frontal sich vor dem jahre 1900 heilig
eine million mal vorbei gegangen unter
und den haben das einfach die kirche ist
ein name getauft
hierbei werden patron von die arme leute
für die beiden ist und sie ist fest kam
ich sehe schon erste oktober bei
gamestar spezielle licht phänomene wie
viel genau so wunderbar was die leute
vor 1000 jahren gemacht haben am ersten
oktober hat die haben die sonnenstrahlen
durch diese kleine röstereien auf der
festlich auf die nordwand und werden die
so schön beleuchtet kein wunder aber die
fresse getötet renoviert werden
damit so verfahren steht berichten zur
stand ich jetzt hohe oder italien
gewertet die hülle besitz der gemeinde
die warnung als viel mehr die vision von
kohle durch den dir streitet wer da muss
ich weiß nicht was da läuft jeden fall
was medien machen dass sie mich
unbedingt die kirchen ende möglich
restaurieren unterhalten für die nächste
generation
[Musik]
wir sind da unterberg software
valtellina ganz im südosten vor der
schweiz ganz gut ohne im val poschiavo
angefangen oder auf der alb sandro
merino oberhalb vom lago di poschiavo
und das da ist poschiavo selber der
hauptort von tal und jetzt wanderung
noch selber das lied oberhalb von
poschiavo und shinobu linie heads ertönt
und die teile da hätten wir einer show
immer gestritten
zum beispiel das wäldchen das leben auf
der karte
das hat bedrohung radio lang zu der
eidgenossenschaft könnte
es ist es unter der geburt von den
trüben sie ermutige kanton graubünden
zwischen dem puschlav von dem weltlichen
ca
eine tribüne mit konfession weitgehend
frei können
darum sind ab mitte vom 16 jahrhundert
reformierte aus italien die das gebiet
geflüchtet
[Musik]
ein ort wo für die reformierte im tal
besondere bedürftigkeit ist selber als
mayer sucht dusik 300 meter oberhalb vom
hauptort poschiavo kids zwei rädern der
katholische und reformierte
der betrieb wie der bekannteste bush
lauren silva semadeni
[Musik]
sido oder somalia italiano der disco
dialekt der schweizer hochdeutsch oder
lieber putsch allemand italiano
pathogene aber mit was in den ruf box
busch erwägen dagegen gesprochen
das ist eine art retter romanisch
italienische rai der sicher lombardische
dialektik abi zwar ich will mir doch wie
abgeschlossen sind einer sitzung soll wo
der grenze zu italien und anders sieht
es am berninapass 2003 meter hoch und zu
der romane habe mir einfach doch kontakt
aber immerhin sie mir ich nie
abgeschlossen wird sein der italienisch
gehört aber nicht zum tessin was so
viele meinen sondern zum kanton
graubünden und sie sind reformiert was
da auch minderheit was hat das für sie
die den 50er jahren reformiert sie
damals hetzner richtige training
zwischen katholiken und reformierter das
kann man heute fast nicht versteuert und
ihr denken über die audio sich fast nur
das mittelalter erlebten mit dem
training an der dr hand mir hängt zum
beispiel an eigene schule kann die
reformierte schulen
wir sind in der klasse 4c und die
parallelklasse von der katholiken sind
48 sie um mir hän der klinischen kam mit
allen new york eng miteinander und so
bin ich stark prägt war der tour dass
minderheiten da sie durch ihr training
von katholiken reformiert sie haben
jederzeit ministerin selber treffen
oberhalb von poschiavo aber verhoben
jetzt eine streife
ja da ist aber interessant wir bei der
kirche die katholische eltern darin so
viel wie sie nun ältere teil der kunden
die reformierte und selber ist für die
reformierte wichtiger bezugspunkt will
die reformierte schulen jedes jahr im
mai ein ausflug der darüber gemacht hat
und dass sich praktisch das größte
reformiert dass sie vom tag
so seien die katholiken
der fertige k immer wieder fronleichnam
oder mitte august und mir herr k nur der
kritik aber amerika richtiges fest kommt
wenn man auch selber sind haben wir
können zeigen so dass sie mir und was er
dort macht ihn selber hat seine
gottesdienste oder selbst immer darauf
gehofft dass alle mitten an
wir haben gesungen in der straße die
kompanie
so sei es laut gesetz zwei lieder und
tänze overclockern die erste sind o'hara
und hängt das glücklich lötet mir händ
wieder einem alzheimer ziska kriegt also
milch mit schokolade welcher
gottesdienst gesicht und der nachts
immer aber kurve und der dorfmusik
haitis abgeholt und den sie marschiert
durchs dorf und am schluss hat der
schulratspräsident seit soll und
bornheimer frei und das ist ein großes
und darum ist dass davids speziell für
die reformierte minderheit richtig
reformieren
[Musik]
ja wie lange händler den karls kinder
ohne vor schiavo ja die schnellste 14 50
minuten kg und die anderen sicher immer
mehr als erstaunt kann
[Musik]
was immer wenn die darin bat poschiavo
siegte reformierte minderheit lang sie
der geschichte das heißt ein minderheit
erhöhten 17
sofort nach der reformation start in
bricht vormann der bischof der dass es
über einen drittel sie sind und der
mafia clans nur ein kirchenchor und wenn
sie gemeinsam genutzt bis zur
gegenreformation also bis zu dem
sogenannter sacrow marcello das heilige
gemetzel übersetzt furchtbares wort wo
im jahr 1620 im veltlin passiert ist und
den auch in brusio und 16 23 poschiavo
betroffenheit dort sind die reformierte
und braucht wurde und die von poschiavo
sind geflüchtet vorher die meisten so
sind mit so viele deutet worden aber im
veltlin sind über 600 seiten gebraucht
wurde und das hat dann der große
veränderungen genau weniger reformierte
k
und es gibt immer wieder aus
wanderungsbewegungen
wir haben die 1900 starke ausgewandert
von denen wo als kaffee tee oder
patissier ausgewandert sind und nach dem
zucker sind und ihre schöne häuser dabei
allerhand feeling auf australien
dort ist gold sucht sie willi lang und
steht für alle arbeit doch obwohl stahl
eigentlich sehr lebendig ich empfinde
das so aber mehr schlaf außerhalb vom
tal sind fast so viele sind mehr als
1000 exil gemeinschaft fahrrad und mehr
ein spezieller namens sharing impulse
das sind die puschlaver wohl mit dem mit
einem stock und azad ausgewandert sind
früher nennt sich heute noch so bush in
buldern
ich habe jetzt das val poschiavo der
hauptort von mir
falls
[Musik]
da silva semadeni hervor verzählt vieles
in dieses land gegangen und eindeutig
schaffen die in spanien oder in sankt
petersburg
als beck oder konditor und einige sind
richtig war und wo die sogenannte
zuckerbäcker zocker sind 1 dort die
häuser baut in poschiavo man seitdem
spaniol viertel und das heißt hüttner so
würde erinnert wo uns spanien zu groß
sind
[Musik]
das spirituelle zentrum für reformierte
im tal ist viele samt die cema trinita
im dorf fern von gustavo zuletzt
arbeitet während die reformierte auf
meine eigene friedhof
da geht sogar gräber verlegt wo gar
nicht warum das so ist erklärt mehr der
paul otto nina nina wie man sehen kann
sind einige der leute im ausland
gestorben und nicht digital ja die
ersten reformierten haben das tal
bereits ende des 17ten jahrhunderts
verlassen
einige sind zurück gekommen einige sind
im ausland gestorben wie dieser mann
hier giacomo ragazzi ist in spanien
gestorben und auch dort begraben hier
steht bloß sein grabstein dir soll daran
erinnern dass dieser mann ursprünglich
aus poschiavo stammt das heißt sein
körper liegt gar nicht hier drehen
hier steht bloß ein grabstein begraben
ist der in spanien
es gibt auch noch weitere solche
grabsteine hier auf dem friedhof
das zeigt sehr schön wie viele leute von
hier nach ganz europa ausgezogen sind
und welche bedeutung die diaspora für
die geschichte dieses tals hat
[Musik]
ja
foto poster moment
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die historische moritat vom 7
jahrhundert dass ich zeit vom 3 sie hat
man ganz europa und macht kämpft aber
haben die richtige religion die rechte
konfession
in der zeit kann sagt rüb und dort seine
tour mit spanien und habsburg als dahin
ist es kloster wo idirect worden ist als
eine art katholisches pohl werk ja aber
das ist lange her und das muster ist
heute gar kreis kloster aber augen zwar
geht's nicht
[Musik]
material sandra im augustinerkloster in
spanien vom dorf das alterszentrum für
spiritualität und kultur
sie stammen aus südamerika aus kolumbien
wie hat es sich ergeben dass sie
ausgerechnet nach poschiavo gekommen
manchmal frage ich mich auch warum gott
zugelassen hat dass ich hier gelandet
bin ich habe einmal als kind am
fernsehen eine werbung gesehen in der
ich den ausdruck mamma mia hörte ich
sagte zu meiner mutter eines tages will
ich in das land gehen wo man mamma mia
sagt aber ich wusste damals natürlich
nicht welches projekt der herr für mich
vorgesehen hatte es gab damals in
kolumbien einen priester der
ursprünglich von hier stand filippo
magnini er suchte nach jungen frauen die
eine berufung verspürten
und so sagte ich zu auch weil ich meinen
eltern nicht zur last fallen wollte wir
hatten wenig zu hause
für mich war das eine große chance aber
auch eine zeit der suche
denn es war nicht immer einfach ich
konnte hier anfänglich kein italienisch
und dann kam ich in ein land wo man
nicht nur italienisch und französisch
spricht sondern auch noch
schweizerdeutsch und was haben sie am
anfang gemacht haben sie mit den händen
gesprochen drehen uns kalt war haben wir
so gemacht und wenn uns heiß war wir
haben uns mit zeichensprache unterhalten
aber wie war das dann für sie als sie
hier im wald poschiavo angekommen sind
mitten in diesen bergen mit den
protestanten und den katholiken wie
haben sie das erlebt
bei uns sind die meisten katholisch und
es gibt viele 6
doch für uns sind alle gleich wenn
jemand hunger hat geben wir ihm zu essen
wenn jemand bettelt verschaffen wir ihm
eine unterkunft
das ist für uns noch mal das alte
kloster ist kein kloster mehr
es ist heute ein zentrum für
spiritualität ökumene und kultur das uhr
kloster meinen sie das mutterhaus sehen
sie das sind meditation und yoga die
religion von heute das muss nicht
unbedingt so sein
jeder soll aus seinem glauben leben und
alle sollten sich gegenseitig
respektieren
es besteht also keine konkurrenz
nein es kann nicht jeder kommen und
sagen das bin ich und so wie ich es sehe
ist es richtig am ende des tages muss
man sagen er hat uns geschafft die leute
die mir nahestehen
meine mit schwester
wir alle sind seine kinder gesehen
paul-otto nina bestritt zwischen
konfessionen zusteht katholik und
reformierte wie es überhaupt zu heute
die geschichte beginnt ein paar jahre
nach der reformation die hier früher
einsetzte nämlich bereits mitte des 16
jahrhunderts zirka 50 jahre lang lebten
beide konfessionen friedlich miteinander
in brusio haben sie sich beispielsweise
die selbe kirche geteilt zuerst feierten
die katholiken messe danach die
protestanten gottesdienst aber dann zu
beginn des 16 jahrhunderts
verschlechterte sich die situation in
berlin wurde ein schreckliches massaker
an den reformierten verfügt auch bei uns
im tal wurden welche ermordet und so war
die friedliche koexistenz plötzlich zu
ende
ja sie waren ja damals bereits in der
minderheit
das haben selbstverständlich nicht alle
katholiken mitgemacht aber es gab halt
extremisten und diese töteten in
poschiavo rund 20 reformiert die anderen
reformierten konnten über den
berninapass ins engadin flüchten
viele blieben dann auch längere zeit
dort
die reformierten wollten sie hier
etablieren und ihren glauben leben
das hat einige katholiken halt gestört
die wollten das wird und so kam es zu
konflikten
aber immer wenn sie jetzt hört auf das
zog läutet über jahrhunderte prägt der
kampf zwischen den konfessionen das
massaker foto das verhältnis von
reformierten kaputt
es ist wirklich nicht einfach das zu
begreifen
aber wenn wir uns in die gegenwart
versetzen und einen konflikt wie jenen
in ex jugoslawien als vergleich
heranziehen dann hilft uns das vor 20 30
jahren bekämpften sich dort auto dachse
und katholiken denselben konflikt
orthodoxe gegen katar
gab es bereits im zweiten weltkrieg und
50 jahre später haben sie den kampf
wieder aufgenommen
solche konflikte überdauern leider
generationen bevor sich die leute
zusammensetzen und sich versöhnen
es ist heute so und war vor 400 jahren
nicht anders wie stets verhaltenen hütt
zwischen der konfessionen poschiavo eine
rutsche bevor tun heute hat sich das
verhältnis untereinander stark
verbessert man lebt friedlich
miteinander
man arbeitet zusammen dieser konflikt
ist jetzt wirklich passé ist geschichte
auf der via valtellina davon bald grenze
oder italien schweiz sich sicher
schmuggler vater und alpen sie aus rot
am ende klar hier hat früher fast jeder
geschmuggelt vor allem im unteren teil
des tals in brusio und trabant zu
produkt und einer party wasser der bund
geschmuggelt wurden zucker kaffee und
zigaretten drogen war jedes mittel recht
es gab zb einmal eine prozession von
brusio zur wallfahrtskirche in tirano
auf der anderen seite der grenze
die marienstatue die mit geführt wurde
war ihnen hohe und wurde mit
schmuggelware gefüllt an der grenze
wurden die teilnehmer der prozession
natürlich nicht kontrolliert und als sie
drüben waren konnten sie den zucker oder
den kaffee oder was auch immer sie
geschmuggelt hatten wieder rausnehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die zugstrecke führt durchs val
poschiavo im süden bischof tiran am
eingang von david macht jetzt auch
[Musik]
die renolit bereits in italien
landesgrenze die gibt es zwar noch aber
hat spielte keine große rolle mehr
[Musik]
fast grenze so durchlässig ist das heim
er vor allem umwelt lehnerz verdanken
wie wo das sieht jahrhunderten abbaut
wird vom winzer aus dem schlaf
[Musik]
solch einem jobwunder zähler und wie
sahen sie seien doch der staat direkt
vom ganzen welt linda stahl straße in
hiltrup wird steiler sind ja herr mir
sagen ist es in deiner in brusio in der
schweiz der heime der rettberg hört
räume sind aber den weltlichen in
italien ist das schweizer wie auch der
italienische wie ein italienischer wohl
voll und ganz
momentan mit italienische vorschriften
produzieren
das heißt mit bezeichnung bio cdu cd
oder egt typische geografische
bezeichnung mir wie er bezeichnet und
auf der etikette mental den usa
produzieren dadurch seien auch ältere
ich an mit filme wohl reformiert sind
katholisch sind geht und gemachte
geschichte ist das waren sie nie gesagt
sie und umstritten da zum teil
sie sind reformiert wenn es richtig weiß
ist es heute neues thema große
unterschied macht man eigentlich nie
wusste dass man nicht zwei verschiedene
kg anett böttger vom auf dem kirchturm
die andere hätten hätten gerufen aber
ich find schlussendlich ist gleich gott
und damit noch die logos oder graben und
es klar das gehört zu der geschichte vom
von berlin und vom tal das sagt man
nicht einfach vergessen wird schicht
vergisst der kann nicht weiter wachse
und witzigen momente ich ins kino -
umstritten
eindrücklich die reise durch das tal
zwischen der berge lange zeit hin und
hergerissen zwischen den konfessionen
und der verschiedenen sprachen
ich hoffe wo das aber gar nicht mehr so
beschäftigt und bedruckt die könnte ihre
eigene spirituelle oder andere seite
[Musik]